Hey guys,
So my wife is ...she's so cute.
She's asking me to just say
something quick before I film.
Because we only show you guys photos every
now and then so I'm setting up everything
here I'm going to do a batch filming
and as you can see it's extremely hot.
I'm sitting here with shorts on .. very
comfy shorts ... and I need your prayers
because when I do these videos I don't
just want to speak what I want to speak.
Daniel.
I need God to work through me.
So that's why we ask you guys to help me.
And there's a lot of noise sometimes out
here and sometimes, you know, the devil just does
not want me to share the gospel in truth and love.
And so I need you guys to pray.
All the prayer warriors, please
pray for me for the next half hour as I'll move
forward to share the gospel in truth and in love.
Thank you guys for the support.
I love you.
And remember God loves you, too.
Bye.